and I wanted to find out a bit more
about you know your your personal
religion because you know you know
Jordan Peterson when he's often asked
about you know what do you actually
believe is is the truth or you know what
do you do you believe God exists and
he'll often say things like well it
depends on what you mean by truth
depends what you mean by exist and he's
such a high-resolution and multiple
perspective sort of guy that he often
doesn't give a real straight answer and
my one of the things that really helped
me along was a listen to the podcast you
were on recently and I forgot the name
of the podcast but it was a similar
conversation to this and you talked
about the fact that you know everyone in
the when you go to a church congregation
you know everyone there has a different
way that they're seeing Christianity and
and and their experience of God and
they're visualizing things in a
different way and that's really stuck
with me especially since I started
attending church and just giving myself
permission to to have my own particular
way of conceptualizing God and Christ
and you know the the fabric of the
universe of the meaning of existence and
and I wondered if you'd be willing to
share a little bit about you know your
own as an artist especially your own
sort of conceptualization of it all
right I think for me I don't think I
don't think for me it's not it's not
necessarily the idea that everybody
develops their own way of seeing of
seeing Christianity but rather that
there's really a hierarchy of capacity
to to understand these things and so the
way that that religious stories and the
way that religious rituals the way that
religion is set up is set up in a way so
that the most illiterate
you know farmer or a literate person on
the street can get something from from
from the experience and the you know the
highest you know doctor of theology can
also get what they need to get from from
that experience and so that that
sometimes accounts for the way that it's
presented and the way that it's
presented with with with stories and
metaphors and and and very visual very
you know it's not it shouldn't be just
an abstract
but I think that for example like if you
take if you take if you take the idea
that you know do you believe that God
exists you know that's a that's a that's
a problematic question it's a it's a
problematic question because if what you
mean I'm gonna play Jordan Peterson I
guess but if what you mean by exists is
that God is phenomenological then no God
is not phenomenological God is never no
classical Christian thinker has ever
believed that God is is on the level of
phenomena God is not quantifiable God is
not measurable and so in that sense God
does not exist God is the source of
being and so in that way you can say
that if only one thing exists God exists
you could say that something like that
yeah in the sense that that it is the
true root of of anything that exists but
it but because of the world the word
exist now has has come to mean almost
only you know anything that anything
that can be measured and quantified then
no God doesn't exist in that way and so
if you read the early early fathers you
read the early early church fathers they
all say God is infinity God is absolute
God is beyond all name all description
all all capacity to formulate anything
about his his essence there is nothing
then you can say that can capture the in
the infinite unbounded Godhead like
there's nothing you can say now having
said that the the everything because God
is the source of being everything in the
world also is showing us God right yeah
so so there's this idea in an Orthodox
theology we call it apophatic theology
which is we understand that you negate
all God's qualities until you reach you
know beyond being and non-being beyond
all possible descriptions and then
there's what's called catyph addict
theology which is that you then see God
in all things to the measure and
that thing can manifest God okay and so
so that's how God becomes the absolute
in every way because he's both cannot be
seen in anything and at the same time
everything is an image of God to a
certain extent okay so so so so I'm
trying to kind of show you how high
let's say or how how high the the
understanding of just talking about
about God really what it is we're
discussing you know especially with
people who are rational core rationalist
they they don't you know they don't
understand that even in the like I said
even in like the very first like third
century you can read church fathers
talking about how every time it says
that God is like this in the text like
God is in heaven or God is or God has
hands or God it's like obviously those
are not descriptions direct descriptions
they're only met their only metaphors
which discussed something that cannot be
described yeah so that's really
important to understand because because
you always hear the atheist say
something like do you believe in God and
then they'll say well which God and
we'll go open it you really afford you
believe in Diana this the Christian God
is not the same because even when
Christianity appeared on the on the the
scene the Romans said that Christians
were atheists that was the accusation
against Christians that they were
atheist because they didn't believe in
the gods because they seem to believe in
a God that didn't exist that was beyond
all possible being and so and so that's
really the route let's say of the of the
God in in the in the Christian and
Jewish and even in the Muslim tradition
so it's really important to to see the
difference let's say and between like
the pagan istic God and the God as being
you know the like we've seen
Christianity undivided Trinity it's
quite different so I have no problem
with like the Creed's at all like I I
recite the Creed tonight and I feel very
like I feel I feel it's important to do
that but I but it's true that if if I
probably if you ask me what a lot of the
things in the cream
mean I wouldn't give you the same answer
as you know like you know the the person
who doesn't who is in educated who
doesn't know theology but the but it's
fine it's flat it's fine with me but I
feel very comfortable with the creeds
yeah right so I think you know one of
the one of the core ideas in
Christianity that is unique from other
religions is is the personal
relationship with God aspect and of
course that's you know as far as
religious practice goes for somebody who
just looks at things in a fairly simple
metaphorical way or accepts the
metaphors as literal truths and disguise
ok God is a is a father in the sky that
I can have a chat with that's how they
can pray and sort of reach out to God
and and and that will work for them in
their their understanding of it but
there's many different ways to do that
and and I want to ask you about your art
making and your carving and is that a is
that a spiritual process for you in the
way you sort of commune with God
I hope so on telling my better in my
better moments it is I mean I carve all
the time so so sadly I wish I could be
always praying when I'm carving but I
would say no obviously not if I just had
a fight with my kids or something I'm
probably not praying when I'm carving
but hopefully so I think that if you see
if you see prayer
or if you see the spiritual life as a as
a whole thing in terms of like every
action that you hoes can be posed in
view of this infinite let's say that
everything you do can be submitted to
God you could say it that way then I
think that for me carving has been a
great opportunity to kind of bring
things in my life together
you know with my work and my interests
and you know my focus into these these
objects that are there to to be in in
communion with with God and then in
communion with with the people that and
it's like it participates in my
communion with people in the church and
plus it is this kind of movement towards
prayer and so so yeah so that's been for
me it's been an amazing thing like it's
hard to even believe that I
can do this like I always everyday that
I'm an icon Carver it's like who's an
icon Carver does it make sense your
that's right I mean I concur but it
doesn't seem like it should be or it
doesn't seem possible let's say